revista de prensa en directo américa
rosa bueno comenzamos en italia donde el
lunes que viene empiezan las votaciones
para elegir al nuevo jefe de estado y
por eso nos hemos fijado en una
explicación del medio italiano corriere
della sera' que dice quién puede ser
entonces el nuevo presidente de italia
rosa bienvenida gracias raúl buenos días
exactamente nos hemos ha querido fijar
en esta explicación porque la forma de
elegir en la jefe de estado en italia es
bien distinta a lo que estamos
acostumbrados por aquí
por ejemplo aquí en américa latina' en
primer lugar cabe destacar que la
función del presidente de italia es
sobre todo la de mantener la unidad
gestionar las crisis políticas pero no
tan no tiene tanta iniciativa ejecutiva
digamos no no es para nada el jefe del
gobierno y lo que hay que tener en
cuenta es que la elección del jefe del
estado se realiza con los votos de mil
nueve grandes electores y estos grandes
electores son senadores congresistas y
58 delegados territoriales
bien lo que sucede es que este 24 de
enero este próximo lunes va a empezar
esta votación y en primer lugar en las
tres primeras rondas de estas votaciones
es necesario alcanzar una mayoría de dos
tercios para poder elegir al presidente
de la república sin embargo a partir de
la cuarta votación ya se requiere
simplemente una mayoría absoluta y ahora
mismo raúl está muy complicado pues se
definiera quién puede ser el 9 el nuevo
jefe del estado pero entre los
candidatos destacan en la actual
ministra de justicia que de ser elegida
sería la primera mujer presidenta en
segundo lugar el actual primer ministro
mario draghi que si es elegido tal como
él mismo ha propuesto y dejaría en el
gobierno el gabinete de ministros sin
una líder lo que podría desencadenar
también en unas nuevas elecciones en
italia pero atención porque también en
la exa el primer ministro y el polémico
empresario también a silvio berlusconi
es el candidato
apoyado por la derecha y por la extrema
derecha vamos a ver de momento parece
que solamente con los votos de esos de
la derecha y de la extrema derecha no
conseguiría tan siquiera una mayoría
absoluta pero hay una figura tal y como
nos comenta el periodista del corriere
della sera' que son los francotiradores
en estas elecciones que significa pues
en este concepto de la política italiana
los miembros que no respetan la
disciplina de su partido por tanto puede
haber sorpresas vamos a ir siguiendo
estas elecciones que van a tener al
lugar como decíamos a partir del lunes
que viene con una votación al día por
temas de restricciones sanitarias por
supuesto que sí rosa quién será el nuevo
presidente de italia pues ya lo veremos
más adelante si nos fijamos ahora en el
continente americano con la portada la
revista 'time' que me encanta de esta
animación de la lluvia que cae sobre el
presidente estadounidense joe biden gear
one año 1 la ilustración es décimo prime
exacto de raúl hemos bueno seleccionado
está esta portada porque ayer ya ya
comentamos los distintos análisis de
este primer año de mandato de joe biden
y aquí vemos bueno como cae la lluvia
como tiene detrás estos test rápidos y
antígenos con esta nueva medida y los
temas que tienes sobre la mesa a
destacar por un lado pues la relación
con rusia como un desarrollo exacto de
cómo está el desarrollo por otro lado
los temas las reformas éstas a que no
puede aprobar el bilbao better o la
reforma electoral es sin dejar de lado
la amenaza de trump 2024 está bueno esta
posible candidatura del ex presidente
que podría pues volver a aparecer de
cara a las próximas elecciones
presidenciales y como yo menos visto
como lo hemos visto hace dos años todo
puede ocurrir en este mundo rosa
cerramos también en estados unidos con
una fotogalería de la crisis de estados
unidos pero en imágenes exacto the
gardian recopila un proyecto que se
llama american in crisis que fue creada
por fotógrafos de la agencia magnum en
los años 60 y quería pues retratar la
sociedad estadounidense en distintos
momentos a críticos de la política y lo
que sucede ahora es que
esta recopilación hará parte de una
exposición en la que se quiere
contraponer los
factores no claves de la política
estadounidense en los años 60
comparándolo con hoy en día vemos
imágenes como por ejemplo de las marchas
selma de 1965 por los derechos civiles
también imágenes de 2020 de las marchas
anti racistas tras el asesinato de
georges floyd no la justicia racial
siempre pues un eje
nacional ahora rosa muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda esa información por
esta revista de prensa lidad si tenemos
mañana pero me acordé que la viernes así
que el lunes con más información de
revista de prensa en directo américa
vamos con nuestro primer invitado al día
[Música]